I have one question and one question only
What is your favorite block in Minecraft?
"What's.. what is your favorite block in Minecraft??"
*intro time*
That's right everybody!
Cringe Tuesdays is here (on a Wednesday...)
and it's here to STAY
Today, we're focusing on Minecon
MiNeCrAfT KiDs are sO criNGEY
I get it. Alright?
First of all, full disclaimer:
All kids are cringy
I've been cringy
I'm 30 and I AM still cringy
But that doesn't mean I can still laugh at kids goddamnit *laughs-*
THAt is nOT-
That is not gonna stop me from laughing in socially inept children. Okay?
I genuinely love these clips
They bring me joy
And I want to experience them;
Even though I probably haven't seen all of them... MULTIPLE TIMES *wheeze-*
"Awkward moments at Minecon 2015"
DanTDM: Okay, one more let's go for it.
Pewds: I love this one-
*Inaudible gibberish*
*Excuse me what???---*
*inaudible gibberish*
yES-- *giggles*
The patience dipped in gold.
Well, how do you respond to something like that? You're standing on stage
Pewds: They can't ask you this question- What do you do?
*Video repeats*
*oF COURSE i wOUld'nt understand to that--*
Pewds: He's casting a spell on Dan!
That's what's really happening here.
It's cute! *BACKHAND CLAPS* It's *BACKHAND CLAPS* cute, aight?
It's not-- cringe if it's cute.
....
Wait, the point is to be cringe-
Well, whatever!- *Plays video*
"How much money do you have?"
*Crowd laughter, boi why that question is ur mom a gold digger?-*
*Mimics-* h ow mu ch m ONEy do y ou h AVE???---
...
GOT EM
"How many of you have autism and if so: Has it helped you in your modding career?"
*Awkward crowd*
*WHAT ARE YOU RECORDING FOR????-*
*Inaudible voices*
Cringe kid: ANd DOnt EVerYOne SpEAk UP aT OnCE
DanTDM: That's a very personal thing to ask them
*Seriously, why---*
"I think we are going to refuse that question, I think"
Kid who asks: oookay then
"Yeah... I'm afraid we have to pass on that one. Sorry."
Well done.
Well--
Well---- Good job deescalating...
...a silly question from a child Antivaxxer
Good job- hehue!- Is it really THAT hard?
Jesus Christ
*Inaudible voices*
"Um... I was wondering um.."
Pewds: Superkai---
"What's the wh-ecommended amount of dedicated wham (RAM) I should have to serv-"
Superkaaii--
What is superkai doing today?
That's all I wanna know. What is Superkai doing??
I just love how it seems like he shocked himself with the question after he asks it--
How much dedicated Wham?????
"Dedicated wham I should have serv-"
s Erve r--
err--
Nnn-- SUPERKAII---
"I'm sorry, could you please repeat your question?"
"Dedicated wAAAAAAAm to a server"
*Inaudible voices*
*Why am I here*
DEDICATED WAAM, IS THAT HARD TO UNDERSTAND?!!-
"Did fans really holds you hostage in room 208 yesterday??"
*Excuse me what?----*
Skydoesminecraft: What
AAHAHAHA-
"Uhhm... Would you like to join *stutters* my-- my dad's minecraft--"
"Minecraft server's MineForgeBat?"
"I've got business cards here, if would you like to join"
"Join--- join his Minecraft-- what?"
"Minecraft-- uhhm..."
"MineForgeCraft.com"
"Oh MineForgebat"
"He's had it up a few years I think now"
Pewds: Awwwww
"He's had it up, a few years I think now"
He's got really good stats, and I was wondering if you would like...
I'LL JOIN--- I'LL GLADLY JOIN!! *slapping hands*
"I'm having a hard time hearing what you said but the--"
Pewds: OH MY GOD!!
Just say yes and move on?! My God?!!
Please?!--
I feel like you are doing equally bad job here!
"Why do you do... what you do...like..."
"Why do you..."
"Do these mod packs for..."
"thousands of people to watch like..."
"What's your purpose in doing that?"
Pewds: *Losing it-* AAH--
This kid's just bringing philosophy into Minecon. (True, dat deepness)
What is the purpose of what you do? What is it? (Philosophy is at it's best in Minecon...)
What is the meaning behind it? (you can say the same about life)
What is the purpose behind...
...These Minecraft pack mods?
Oh God. It's beautiful, I haven't--
I haven't had the stomach to sit through one of these before
"What do you have to like further improve the mobs like?" (I think he needs vocal Grammarly)
"I'm sorry?"
"Like what are you doing to further improve the mobs?" (English essay alert)
"How we program them?"
"Like what... what are any movements or anything are being added into the game?"
"I'm sorry I don't understand"
"I don't the speaker set up is good here, um...."
(The moment of silence has occurred..)
"Sorry :("
OH MY GOD! x2 (Ikr?)
I really-- this is-- the kids are not the problem.
The kids are just being kids! It's the panellists! (agreed)
Oh my God..
What are you doing to help increase it?--
We're gonna make them faster--
We're gonna make them stronger and we're gonna make them look better
Jesus Christ. Just say anything do it instead of--
...nO.
"What do I do to uhmm.. "
"Fix my uhm.."
"Map. I was using Web powered frames--"
Pewds: AAHAAAHHHH
Look at the face of this d uu u de--
Look at the dropping--
Oooohohoho---- ahahaha!---
*Wheeze* ahahaha-
Oh G o d---
Strength.... sweet strength is just flowing through my body, t HE c RIngE--
Just surges through my blood veins and vessel
And I feel more powerful and weak at the same time
Ah~~
(WE HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE)
Excuse me for interrupting this video
Nord VPN, let me tell you ALL about it.
Pfft, you're browsing internet unprotected?? (Y ep)
pFFT-- You don't have a VPN...
...Even though Article 13 passed, and it's a worldwide issue that you need to somehow get BY through with????
Well, don't worry..
I'm here to help *KABOOSH--*
With a VPN: You can appear like you're browsing anywhere on the Internet.
If Bish Lasagna is blocked in India. (P.S we are sorry for the memes. just get NordVPN)
Don't worry, baby
Just download the NordVPN.
Just check out nordvpn.com/PewDiePie
And...
You'll get 75% off! That's a great price (:D)
$2.99 for 36 Months...
And you get an extra month if you use PewDiePie
(Oh sweet, thanks)
You're welcome!
VPN helps you BROWSE SAFELY on the Internet... (or you could watch Bish lasagna in India)
If you're traveling using public Wi-Fi...
your risk-- easily getting hackerd dackerd
But nO!--
VPN will solve that problem
I also on a personal level...
I'm really glad that there are actually programs now
That the world seems to become more and more restricted
By dummy dumb rules!
That are dummy dumb! (and Dumb)
Easy way to get past it... use a VPN
I highly recommend it. I use it as well. You can also use it on your phone (USE IT)
It's nice simple easy and smooth.
Just like my-- ... (oh heck no demonization)
Check out link description
You're welcome, broskis~ Keep watching video now
"Where did the name SkythekidRS and Ihascupquake come from cuz I know Jordan and..."
"*sad sigh*"
[Classic Pewds laugh]
When you realize, mid-sentence...
That you don't really give a (nope)--- *chuckles*
About the question.
I already get the question--- Goddamn it-- (Yep-)
"There you go buddy"
"I have one question"
"Can you sign this?"
*Crowd laughter-*
"ME?-"
"All of you!-"
"That's your question????----"
Oh my God-
I can relate to this so much--
It was the same one we did our panel and everyones like--
"CAN I HAVE A HUUG???-" And it's like--
That's nOT A QUESTION!!! [That audio clipping tho]
I mean, technically IT IS, but nO--
*WARNING: LOUD NOISE COMING-*
"AHHHHHHHHHHHHH"
(rip yer ears eh?-)
*wheezes-* I was not ready for that-- ahahahaha--- (none of us were)
"Okay! Now here's an epic CaptainSparkle backflip!"
*LOUD NOISE INCOMING AGAIN----*
Pewds: aaaaaHHHHH-----
S t o p plee a se--- ;;w;;"
"What do you think will happen with the YouTuber community, when the uhh"
"...Minecraft will die? Or it's going to be over?"
(Don't even--)  (that will never happen)
Plot twist: Minecraft never dies (truth)
He knew all the long--
"You have sort of like plans on how to stop sort of like corporate creep getting into Moyang---" (Oh?----)
Pewds: AAAAHAHAHAH-- *Wheeze--*
Ahhh-- That's the funny one-- Phahahaha!
Some of these age so beautifully...
As a parent, I really appreciate you using all the appropriate language in your videos
"And uhmm.." *Then crowd cheer*
(Meanwhile...) not saying what he's saying just know that its bad
I'm a big fan of-- (probably pewdiepie sub btw)
Pewds: Ahahahahaha!--
Ohooh God-- Ahahahahaha!--- *Wheezes--*
Jordan took that compliment
Like a---- he--- he's a saint---
...and then
My name is Dante
"I've actually written a parody song and I'm wondering if you could looked at it. So... "(SHUTDOWN)
"Uhhmm... As far as the... The parody stuff I..."
"I tend to try keeping it all the lyrics to..."
"Me writing them and then sort of bouncing them off....."
"Could you like... Just tell me how you like it???"
"If you contact me via Twitter or something... I can..."
"I can do my best to get back to you on that"
"So should I give this to you?"
*awkward silence*
*random clapping*    *A couple of woohoos*
"Thank you!"
*Facepalm noises--*
"Oh hey!"
"Hi!"
"Wait, this is gonna look weird, but you can't hear--- hello!"
Pewds: ppfft ahahahah!--
(ooooh k ay---- Things couldn't get any weirder--)
Oohh God yes--
Why is it so good?---
So good-- I love it so much.
It makes me happy--
I don't get it
"What's that next to it?--"
Pewds: u HMM---
(Uh oh----)
That final 'Uhm!'
Jesus Christ---
Oh God--- They're clearly in the costume
For a reason---
"Hi!"
"There's a bit of a rivalry between me and my friends back at home" (what friends?) [<-Rude]
"About whether cows or pigs are better..."
"and I was wondering are there going to be any cow pets in the game at any point?"
"A-Are you the--- are you the cow guy?-"
"Yeah"
"Awww..."
(Big sad)
"Now, today is my birthday"
"It's not--- I-I'm not gonna ask you see me happy birthday but..."
"Everyone spam Cap in the chat! Annnd..."
"Let's give a nice loud"
"Kaaaappaaaaa--"
(Boi---)
"Kaaaa-- No?-- You guys su c K-- Try again!--"
"Kaaaappaaaaa---"
(w  h  y----)
"This is cringy, this is cringy"
"I'm sorry! Cringe compilation! Hi!"
"I have no idea, yeah"
"I have a feeling it's gonna be a long hour"
Thahahahaha--
That guy looks so out of place---
"Hello guys, I want to design games and stuff and a friend of mine said if I give him 750 pounds"
"you'd put this game-- it'll make it happen for me"
"But it's gotta be cash"
"would you support me and sort of follow me in your YouTubes?"
"Yeah"
"Well best of luck."
"Yeah, hope it goes good for you man."
"But would you follow me with it though with your YouTubes?"
"Yeah, of course"
"Sure, man"
*Pewd's anguish*
"H-have, have I got your word on that?"
"Yes, sure."
"And will you be my friend?"
"I like to think we're already friends?"
"Yeah, I got news for you. We're already friends"
"Yeah"
"Thanks guys (background: Yep!)"
(That's heartwarming and cringe I don't know how to feel about that)
*cringes*
[A dab for the youths?]
The thing with cringe is...
What doesn't kill you makes you stronger
I like to think so at least. I like to think that you're suffering for a reason
My friend wants 750 dollars in cash
It has to be cash
And he's gonna make a game
Will you guys follow me on the YouTubes?
Oooooohhhhhhhhhhh
God damn it what happened to the game?
People don't know but this is actually how Tuber Simulator it was funded *laughs*
"See this last question and this is the last one."
"The pressure!!!"
"How many kids have you entertained?"
*pewds laughing for ages*
Oh yes yes *laughing*
*mimics* hOw MaNY kIDs HaVE yOU eNTerTAineD?
Five.
"What... What is your favourite block in Minecraft?"
"Favorite blooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooock..."
God, how can I pick one?
I mean, I get it. It can't be easy. I'm not trying to pretend like I'm better
I'm sure if I was there it would be I would I would 100% been in this compilations
Okay, whether I was a youtuber or an audience *struggles* audience member *struggles again* audience member. Jesus Christ.
"Okay, one more. Let's go for it"
*inaudible gibberish*
"I'm sorr- Wait what was that sorry?"
*ultimate cuteness*
*More inaudible gibberish* (Would you like to come to my house?)
"Come to your house?"
"Are you making tea? I'll come if you make tea"
*more cuteness*
It's so sweet and so innocent
It's so cute
"Females don't very often refer to themselves as gamers"
"So you don't realize how many females are gamers"
"Because it's more of a guy thing to label themselves"
"Whereas girls are just like it's something I do"
"Anyone can be a gamer even if it's like doing a Soodookoo [sudoku] on your phone"
Yes I forgot about that clip
*More laughing* (I think Pewds is broken)
It was actually not a bad answer and then she just had to jump in with that line
to just ruin the whole thing *more laughing*
Hey man I'm not hating. I have sudoku on my Phone guess I'm a gamer
That's right. Guess I'm a gamer after all, huh
"I want you to make some noise if you have a YouTube channel"
*a lot of cheers*
All right, this is as much as I can stomach that was beautiful I feel fantastic
Smash like subscribe and goodbye
*close your ears, screams coming*